foreign
[Music]
this time of year is critical to many
businesses if you've had a sluggish
summer season or a slow start to the
year at the end of the year is kind of
make Make It or Break It time and so
it's critical to encourage people to not
just enjoy the convenience of shopping
online but to come out and engage with
the community because we're still here
and we're still excited to see your
smiling faces
I'm hearing from some businesses that
they're having an incredible holiday
season
and I'm hearing from some that you know
they'd like to see more traffic and more
sales as well it's been all hands on
deck experience to survive being a small
business in downtown you know I've
unfortunately seen a lot of my fellow
business owners have to close their
doors forever a Nike store in northeast
Portland has closed its doors and some
wonder if theft is the reason they say
three teenagers crashed stolen cars into
three three different dispensaries so
they could burglarize them businesses
small and large deciding their risk
isn't worth staying in the Rose City so
if our Starbucks has closed three of
their cafes in Portland citing safety
concerns margulous Jewelers made the
decision to shut down shop after 90
years in Portland blaming the city and
county leaders for not cleaning up
downtown and getting a handle on crime
we've been hearing a lot from businesses
that they were getting broken into and
then some getting broken into multiple
times 63 percent of our businesses had
been broken into
man that's crazy
we've had our window broken and
had to replace it and which was very
costly because a lot of these expenses
are not covered in our lease agreements
and so it was difficult you know Finding
funds to replace a window on top of the
fact that there's a glass shortage in
the city because it's so prevalent we
had another incident where our car was
broken into on the way to provide
services for a wedding
we loaded you know about six to seven
thousand dollars worth of lighting
equipment and makeup kits and we
experienced a smash and grab
unfortunately
so there are still some of those things
going on businesses go deeper into debt
by having to replace those items or
repair things within their stores or to
try and get their stock replenished
there are some businesses that are
afraid to take the boards down still
very early on I decided to not have my
windows boarded up because I felt like
the city had fallen into a deep sadness
and a deep Longing To kind of return to
normal this holiday season is truly very
very important these are the streets
where we work where we play so
it's incumbent upon all of us to
maintain this this fabric of our city by
by choosing to shop at these these local
businesses you would think that one
might throw their arms up in the air and
give up but The Optimist I don't see the
point in giving up because that's not
going to change things it's not going to
make anything better we just need to
find solutions to these problems and
pull together as a community and you
know hopefully get past this point
foreign